on the prime minister looking for hosting
mr president donald ladies and
gentlemen it is a great pleasure to be
here in montreal once again and i
would like to thank the prime minister
for his welcome and his hospitality so
his team
the world in which we live
today is complex and difficult
and for this it calls more than ever
for openness, cooperation and
respect for a global order based on the
rules and it is in this spirit that
the strategic partnership agreement is inscribed
between canada and the european union
because when we join
forces and do much more better
than we would, with friendship alone
the partnership with canada
is very strong we share the same
values ​​and in particular this example for
example in  the fight against
climate change the preservation of our
palace planet
i welcome the signing
today with my friend
minister mckenna on the partner  iat on
the oceans which testifies to our
common determination to defend the
oceans what is necessary is a
shared international responsibility
because 60% of the oceans are located
outside territorial waters end of
everything you to gather aspres minister
santos yields 2 understanding  economic and
trade agreement between felt a
test
yes this gold stand up for trade
agreement between this number and
professional applications jboss
showcase presence in agen christ brings a crowd there
actually discord and scout
economically does not make them full
who decide s  they want to progress
after many
a call turn over city the quality of the
land sea dogs and m and 2.19 to the
price stability objective
thank you